párate mayor que cero una partícula que
se mueve a lo largo de la curva en el
plano x y tiene un vector posición
xd tema 7 entonces la coordenada x de su
posición está dada por la función
paramétrica x dt y la coordenada jet de
su posición está dada por la función
paramétrica en 7 y tiene un vector
velocidad dado por vedette e igual al
coseno de t cuadrada como en elevado al
0.5 t entonces la componente x del
vector velocidad es coseno de t cuadrada
y la componente 10 del vector velocidad
es el elevado a la 0.5 y después dicen
ente igual a 1 la partícula se encuentra
en el punto 35 encuentran la coordenada
x de la posición de la particular ente
igualados como resolvemos esto
bueno pues podemos ver la coordenada x
ente igualados
x de 2 y bueno no nos dan x de 2 de
manera directa pero lo que podemos decir
es que esto va a ser igual a x de 1 es
decir la coordenada x en el tiempo te
iguala 1 más un cierto cambio en x y
bueno este cierto cambio en x va a ser
lo que cambiamos del tiempo te iguala 1
al tiempo t igualados entonces cuánto va
a ser este cambio en x bueno lo que sí
sabemos es el vector velocidad de hecho
nos vamos a fijar en especial en la
componente x del vector velocidad porque
es justo lo que buscamos sabemos que la
componente x del vector velocidad es una
función de tema que es poseen o dt
cuadrado déjeme apuntarlo es coseno d
elevado al cuadrado bien y si éste
coseno dt cuadrada lo multiplicamos por
un pequeño cambio en el tiempo entonces
esto nos dará un pequeño cambio en la x
porque observamos si multiplicas la
velocidad por un pequeño cambio en el
tiempo obtendrás el desplazamiento ahora
qué te parece si sumamos todos estos
pequeños cambios desde el tiempo te
iguala 1 hasta el tiempo te igual a 2
recuerda que básicamente este delta de x
nos estamos fijando en él desde el
tiempo de igual a 1 t igual a 1 al
tiempo de igual a 2 y por lo tanto
podemos decir ahora que x de 2 x de 2 va
a ser igual a quien bueno a x de 1 pero
eso lo sabemos porque aquí dice que en
el tiempo de igual a 1 se encuentra en
el punto 35 es decir que x de uno es 3
entonces esto de aquí
y me quedarían tres más el cambio en x
que es esta integral que tengo aquí y
quiero que estés muy seguro de lo que
está sucediendo recuerda cuánto nos
movemos en un pequeño cambio en el
tiempo bueno pues si tomamos a nuestra
velocidad en esa dimensión y a eso lo
multiplicamos por un pequeño cambio en
el tiempo nos va a dar el desplazamiento
en esa dirección y después si tomamos la
suma de todos ellos desde el tiempo de
igual a 1 hasta el tiempo t igualados
nos va a dar lo que queremos y para
nuestra suerte en esta parte del examen
ap podemos sacar nuestra calculadora
para resolver esta integral así que
vamos a sacarla bueno pues esto va a ser
y déjame ponerla por aquí nos vamos a
tomar a 3
la integral y para eso nos vamos a ir a
la función mar y nos vamos a ir al 9 a
la integral definida perfecto de y bueno
vamos a tomarnos la función coseno estoy
suponiendo que estoy en radiales eso es
importante la función coseno de y bueno
voy a poner
dt esto elevado al cuadrado
cierro paréntesis y después hay que
poner la variable bajo en la cual
estamos tomando la integral que esté y
después hay que poner los límites de
integración
los límites son de 1 a 2 así que de 1 a
2 de lujo y cierro paréntesis de esta
integral definida y si ahora le pongo
enter entonces me dan 2 puntos 55 7
redondeado 2 puntos 55 7 así que si me
voy para acá voy a decir que esto es
aproximadamente aproximadamente
2.55 7 y de lujo ya tengo esto
redondeado y ya con esto hemos acabado
este problema